I want you back I'm not very good at  this I've never wanted to try again that  dinner with me okay fine I will have  dinner with you because I'm hungry but  we are only talking then that is it  gotta be quicker than that  great are you happy I've never been  happier  [Music]  take him off  [Music]  you got me  your boyfriend has a reputation do you  want to be kept or have respect  [Music]  do you think you're the first woman who  tried to save him  he's changing that what he wants anymore  but it's what he needs  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you're just gonna stand there gawking  yes  [Music]  [Music]  if something were to happen to you I  could never forgive myself  [Music]